This video is brought to you by Squarespace from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Jack out Squarespace through the link in the description below more on them in a
bit,
The science sufficient lies at the very heart of our ability to harness nuclear
power, regardless of whether it's used for weapons,
energy or some unknown purpose,
we wouldn't have any of it had one of the world's most brilliant scientific
minds not unlocked its secrets in 1944,
the Nobel committee awarded a German scientist named Otto Hahn,
the Nobel prize in chemistry. It was for his discovery of nuclear fission.
And he would go on to be known as the so-called father of nuclear chemistry.
Han was a brilliant researcher, scientist and chemists.
So that's all well and good, but it's only part of the story.
He didn't conduct his research alone. In fact,
when it came time to publicly explain his findings,
he had some difficulty articulating the very science.
He was given credit for pioneering that's because it was another researcher
who did much of the work before she was purposefully excluded from the
published paper because she was female and Jewish.
Her name was Lisa Meitner errands in the decades. Following Hans Nobel prize.
Her continued anonymity has been consistently identified as one of the most
blatant instances of sexism and prejudice in the scientific community.
Mike Miller was born in Vienna in 1878, though.
There is some debate about that exact date.
She had always observed her birthday on November the seventh,
but according to official records, she had been born on November the 17th.
Just why there is a difference in dates. Isn't clear,
perhaps it was a cleric Alara no one cared enough to fix.
It's also been suggested that a parent's Hedwig and Philip might not
intentionally delayed their submission of all the proper paperwork regardless.
Lisa's birth stands in sharp contrast to other parts of Europe where
such an era would have caused chaos for Mike. Nah,
it just didn't seem to matter up.
The mountain of family had only moved to Vienna fairly recently. In fact,
it was only recently that they had adopted their last name.
It was a gift from her great, great grandfather who adopted the name,
my thinner as a nod to that ancestral home in Moravia,
they hadn't bothered with a surname before and only added one.
When Connie's of Joseph.
The second is mandated the use of a surname for any family availing themselves
of civil services, like education and employment.
And this was the first time the family enjoyed the benefits that others took for
granted others. That is who weren't Jewish,
just a few generations later, the Kaiser's edict.
So it opens the doors of the center.
It was a bustling hub of liberal advancements and sure it was crowded,
highly unsanitary plagues by cholera and the suicide rate was high.
But for the first time the Jewish men and women found themselves eligible for
full participation in activities and occupations that were previously off
limits. Pellet bike.
Now was one of the first Jewish man who could study and practice law.
And the social standing afforded to him by his occupation in the city,
allowed him to open up his home to all the Vienna's most progressive citizens.
They might know home.
Then Leopold starts just a Stone's throw from the Daniel canal was a gathering
place for politicians, lawmakers, and entertainers.
At times they would discuss the future of their beloved city,
but often they just wanted to play chess and socialize with other free thinking
individuals. Lisa was the third of eight children.
Her family was by no means rich,
but they were comfortably middle-class because her family had enough money to
pursue hobbies.
She and her siblings were encouraged to explore the world around them and find
that passions, the siblings all studied music. And for Lisa,
the days she spent playing the piano as a child sparked passion that lasted for
the rest of her life. But when it came to matters of more formal education,
she was at a major disadvantage simply because she was a girl.
Fortunately Lisa's parents were adamant that all their children would receive a
similar opportunities in life.
So they hired private teachers and tutors to help keep everyone up to speed and
likeness studied subjects like math, but only basic bookkeeping.
Along with history, some geography and a bit of science.
There were also a few subjects that seems a bit out of touch today. Singing,
drawing, gymnastics, and something that was simply called feminine handiwork,
but all subjects that she studied, the teachers noted that her grades were good,
but her discipline was lacking. She was bored much later.
Lisa would look back on early schooling with a small Pang of regret writing.
Although I had a very marked Benz for mathematics and physics from my early
years, I did not begin a life of study immediately.
Thinking back to the time of my youth,
one realizes with some astonishments how many problems then existed in the lives
of ordinary young girls,
which now seem almost unimaginable among the most difficult of these problems
was the possibility of normal intellectual training.
By the time Lisa and her sisters were looking for secondary education options.
The firm glass ceiling that had been in place was beginning to crumble.
When it came to educating women,
there were only two countries where aspiring female students faced more
opposition than they did in Austria. And that was Turkey and Germany.
Austria had bought women for university for a long time, but in 1897,
women were finally granted access to higher education. Even as university,
it became a viable option. New problems emerged for one thing,
all these new troublemakers were required to pass entrance exams in order to
gain access to universities. Fortunately,
the girls of the mine family had been well-prepared by that parents,
elder sister just sell a pollster exams and did medical school in 1900.
And Lisa pushed herself to compress eight years of schooling down into two.
She studied mathematics, physics, mineralogy, logic, religion, Latin, Greek,
and botany.
It was a long and difficult periods during which a family said that they never
saw her without a book of some kind in the end, though,
all of that hard work paid off when Lisa Meitner turns 21,
she enrolled at the university of Vienna and became the first woman to study
physics that when she graduated, she was only the second female students to an,
a PhD from the school
I with studying at university.
She found a teacher who encouraged her to enter the field of physics that was
Ludovic Boltzmann,
a physicist who also graduated from the university and worked in statistical
mechanics.
Boltzmann was a little different than the other professors and authority figures
that should match this.
He accepted women in fields of higher learning without hesitation.
He was married to a maths and physics teacher.
And after role might have describes him as a pure soul full of goodness of heart
idealism and reverends. For the wonder of the natural order of things.
By the time I met him, Boltzmann was already struggling with ill health in 1906,
Boltzmann took his own life.
It was a tragic events yet one that would serendipitously lead to a meeting.
What changed Mike and his life among those who traveled to Vienna to pay their
respects of Boltzmann's funeral was max plank. The father of quantum theory,
he had Sue was a potential roadblock.
Planchet unconditionally refused to welcome women to his lectures,
but they might not.
He made an exception sort of when she picks up and to move to Berlin,
to continue our studies. She found that even though playing good,
opens the door to his lectures,
the doors do the practical experiments or laboratories were still firmly shut
and locked tight. And the university of Berlin is where Mike numb met Otto Hahn.
The chemist wheat mentioned before he was working and a somewhat improvised
radio chemistry lab.
And since it was completely separate from planks off limits of the trees
complete with a separate entrance and everything,
she could go there to study and research.
She would be an unpaid assistant of course,
but given the uphill battle she was facing for acceptance,
she knew she couldn't underestimate the value of a foot in the door.
And if you're looking the great value from something you should definitely
consider today's sponsor Squarespace. Now, a couple of simple things, but one,
maybe you've got some idea for a business or a website in your minds kind of
knocking around. Ooh, is that a good idea? Well, number two,
you don't know if that's a good idea,
unless you get it out there into the world.
And I know that can be daunting because you know,
pursuing new things kind of is,
but not knowing how to set up a website is not an excuse.
There are no excuses available with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to.
You want to sell something online? Yes.
Easy to set up a store with Squarespace or a podcast,
or maybe starting a YouTube channel,
or you want a website to compliment that it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can customize your heart's content,
or you can from scratch or easily move over from an
existing domain, making everything super easy to manage.
Don't start from scratch. Just use a template, no excuses.
And once you've gone through the super easy customization process,
there's no updates patches. There's no tank BS to deal with.
Squarespace also handles all our website. He stopped podcasts. Yes.
Mailing lists. Yes. Social integrations. Yes.
And much more like I say,
Squarespace removes the excuses to your dreams.
Just go get started. Now, just do it. Also 24 seven customer support.
You are there to help you whenever you've got a question,
had to squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
to save 10% off your first purchase of a website or a domain.
And let's get back to the video,
Not work side by side for a long time.
And it was a partnership that was interrupted several times by some of the most
iconic events of the 20th century. Even in the small makeshift lab,
the dynamic duo had momentous days of achievements,
including the discovery of several new isotypes.
It was during this time that my not also wrote and presented several papers on
beta radiation by 1912,
hardened might not still operating under the lead assistant paradigm had moved
from their makeshift basement laboratory to the Kaiser Ville helm,
gazelle shaft,
where Han accepted a position as the head of the radioactivity Institute.
It was a huge step up, but it wasn't long before the outbreak of world war one,
but their work on hold Hom spent the warriors working under Fritz Harbor and
researching the use of chemical weapons. By all accounts,
his participation was unwilling chemical weapons schools,
less than 1% of world war, one fatalities,
but the physical and psychological effects of the use led to the Geneva
conventions,
prohibition of such weapons in future conflicts while Han blade war chemist
might know,
volunteered with the Austrian army as a nurse working mostly with x-ray
technology, they didn't return to civilian life until 1917.
At which point they returned to their work. That's the key WG by this time,
my no is no longer a mirror assistant.
She was appointed to the head of the institutes physics division.
She had been recognized for a work and to have potential, certainly,
but there were plenty of reminders that her abilities were viewed with a double
dose of skepticism when she became Berlin university's first female professor in
1926,
Lisa gave her first lecture on radioactivity and cosmic physics.
It's an unthinkably complicated subject,
and it was also reported as a section of cosmetic physics,
typo or not.
It represented a common problem for how women were viewed in the workplace at
the time minor and Han made a number of subatomic particle discoveries
throughout the 1920s and regularly published their research.
But it wasn't until the of world war two,
that James Chadwick's discovery of the neutron gave the field a major boost,
suddenly researchers while hypothesizing that it would be possible to create a
new elements in the lab.
And teams of scientists were racing to see who could get that first minor.
And hadn't added two more crucial elements,
no pun intended to their research team.
Fritch Strassman and minus nephew also fresh together.
They began trying to identify the decay patterns that formed when uranium was
bombarded by the recently discovered neutrons.
And here is where things get complicated,
not just for Meitner hon and their partnership,
but for pretty much everyone else. The Nazi policy of, again,
consolidating power in Europe at this time.
And remember my no wasn't just female. She was also from a Jewish family, hates,
runs deep while their parents had never really been practicing Jews that
children all had registered within the Jewish community.
Even though the children had actively accepted different faiths,
minus sisters were baptized Catholics, Bob,
she herself attended Protestant services.
It just didn't matter to the Nazis that heritage was Jewish.
And that's all that was seen in the end as Hitler Rose to power minus or other
Jewish scientists she had worked with suddenly started to disappear.
Even her nephew fled for a while. She was protected by her Austrian citizenship.
She just kept her head down to avoid drawing any unnecessary attention to
herself.
Eventually she was officially dismissed from her position at the university of
Berlin nuns while she kept conducting our research at the Institute,
her name was stricken from the record and removed from any official documents
pertaining to our findings pawn alone, received credit for her work. Lisa,
trying to ignore the problem, focusing on her work and nothing else.
But when Austria was annexed by Germany,
it became clear that her life was no longer safe in Germany.
She also realized that she didn't have the support of most of our colleagues
consider the remarks of a coworker named cut has Sue remained very vocal
about her continued presence in the research community? Oh,
one point has lemons. Is this the Gus in danger,
this Institute in July of 1938,
a car dropped her off at a train station in Berlin.
She had already stayed too long.
There were now new laws in place and no scientists were allowed to leave the
country or even to get documents that would allow them to do so. In the future,
the train ride from Berlin to the Dutch border had to be unthinkably long and
unbearably terrifying. She was traveling with a Dutch chemist named Dick Costa,
and he had arranged for her to be welcomed to the Netherlands,
but she had to get across the border first.
And the only document she had was her outdated Austrian passport.
In her later years,
might've recalled sitting horrified as an officer of the Nazi military check
tech credentials. I got so frightened. My heart almost stopped beating.
I knew that the Nazis had just declared open season on the Jews that the hunt
was on for 10 minutes. I sat there and waited 10 minutes.
That seemed like so many hours.
Then one of the Nazi officials returns and handed me back my passport without a
word within just a few months. Mine was living in Stockholm.
She and Han maintained correspondence. Even as Han continued,
the experiments that worked on with the help of Straussman.
They discovered that they could turn a radioactive substance into something that
was almost barium, but not quite. It was much too license.
They couldn't make heads or tails of what that founds mine. His nephew,
who had moved to Copenhagen after his escape from Germany was visiting her that
Christmas.
The two report over the odd findings eventually arriving it's one inescapable
truth. The uranium from their experiments had been split,
releasing nuclear energy.
They needed a name to refer to this process and they dubbed it. Fishing.
Mine is Dutch discovery is where our story gets a little hazy.
When it was time for Hunter publishes work and tell the world what that
discovered.
He had to carefully consider what names he should attribute to the project.
Technically it was he and Strassman who conducted the experiments,
but it was Mike who had told him what to look for.
She was also the chief architect behind the interpretation of the results and
Walnut plainly seems like they should have shared credits.
Han knew that adding a Jewish women's name to his work from the house of Nazi
Germany would have all but destroyed his career.
So he published his paper on fishing without giving her any mention.
There was a little bit of Epic justice here that went on,
published his findings. He left out a fairly important bits.
That explains exactly how uranium could be splits into two barium, atoms.
He was vague about the actual mechanics, not fully comprehending them himself.
Unfortunately it might not could explain it.
So she did just ask a few weeks after the discovery had been published,
she wrote a letter to the editor of nature and explained how the process had
been successfully achieved.
This was the first place where the term efficient actually appeared.
It only took a few months for word of the discovery to spread by April, 1939,
the German government was pushing it scientists to find a way to weaponize the
discovery ends by August.
Einstein was issuing severe warnings on what would happen if the world figured
out how to do it all the while Han remained in Nazi,
Germany might not continue to work with them.
All beers with drastically changed opinions on him,
alongside the other scientists who remains in Nazi controlled territory in a
lesser, she never sends might not confess this.
I must write this to you because so much depends for both Germany and yourselves
on your recognizing what you allow to happen.
You betrayed Germany itself because even when the war was already quite
hopeless, you did not arm yourself against the senseless destruction.
If you could have seen, feel self. Those who came there from the case.
It was the gentleman.
Physicist, Verna Heisenberg,
who was put in charge of harnessing the power of nuclear efficient for practical
applications, or in other words,
creating a fish and a weapon he failed where America succeeded giving rise to
one of Lisa is more famous nicknames. The mother of the atom bomb.
She was awarded this epithet,
despite the fact that she had refused to do any work on the Manhattan project,
a nicknamed bothered her.
She was steadfast in her desire to have nothing to do with weaponized fishing.
She spent the rest of the war in Sweden, sticking firmly to our declaration.
I will have nothing to do with a bomb.
It's a long-standing misconception to that.
Minor was directly responsible for the atom bomb. In 1945,
she was honored by the women's press club and had dinner with president Harry S
Truman you're set to her. So all,
let us a lady who got us into all of this as well.
If that made you cringe well, you are not alone minors in target.
It was punctuated by slight spaced on her agenda and her family's Jewish
history. And it wasn't just the Nobel prize committee that did us,
although there's was perhaps the most gross oversight.
It is certainly there's that is most remembered as they have gone back to look
at the circumstances around her emission from Nobel history.
So whatever historian said really happens around minus Nobel prize. No right?
Who or what is to blame it's more complex.
Then it seems at first glance and according to Gustaf call strands curator of
the Nobel museum,
both Han and Mike were nominated for the prize and many consider it to be an
emission that she did not receive it.
Historians who have looked in the archives have determined that the committee
member who evaluated mindness candidacy made a mistake and underestimated her
influence in the discovery. The museum might realize that now,
but there was never any move made by the committee.
You do formally address their oversight, Oh, by most accounts excepted the snob,
but it still had to hut for what it's worth.
There was no grand celebration for Han.
He was in England interns with other German scientists.
When he got words that he had one, it was 1945.
After the bombing of Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
he sank into such a deep despair that he considered suicide.
Instead he hearing sounds Germany accepted a position at the max Planck
Institute and became an active voice in the campaign against nuclear weapons.
As for Meitner. She refused to ever return to Germany.
She briefly became a Swedish citizen before eventually settling in England for
her retirement years.
The role that work plays in the building of the atom bomb seems to horns are
more than the loss of any accolades. Miner never stopped speaking to hon.
They continue to write that as an hon eventually admitted to her that she had
been right about his responsibilities during the war for our 80th birthday in
1958, he wrote to her, we all knew that injustice was taking place,
but we didn't want to see it.
We deceived ourselves come the in 1933,
I followed a flag that should have been torn down immediately. I did not do so.
And now I must bear responsibility for it. Well,
the Nobel prize committee never fixed.
What many consider a grievous oversight minor did receive some recognition for
how walk in 1966,
the U S department of energy awarded her hon and Straussman Enrico Fermi awards
given for pioneering research in the naturally occurring and extensive
experimental studies leading to the discovery efficient.
She was recognized with a slew of other awards and honors too.
She was nominated for a Nobel prize.
Three times was given a number of honorary doctorates and perhaps best of all,
than to name to an asteroid and elements and a series of craters on both Venus
and the moon. Those are all great gestures,
but it could also be argued that they came a few decades too late Meitner turns
89 in 1968 and passed away after a heart attack, a full,
a broken hip and a series of small strokes,
her nephew and longtime collaborator, rotor avatar,
which read Lisa might not a physicist who never lost her humanity.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check it off. Fantastic sponsors Squarespace.
There is a link to them below and thank you for watching.